oh yeah and then never said when we were
in Morocco yeah there was the dogs and
then there was a lot of cats and so then
we would be doing a scene and then Cat
Cat and then the dogs were just like but
the thing is what do you think happens
when we die
Keanu Reeves I know that the ones who
love us will miss us what is your secret
for always staying down there forever
well I mean gravity movies have made so
much money three and a half billion
dollars entertain entertain right yes
because this is a big deal for me right
it's my name it's my name and I
literally go to the ocean and you scream
it's what is the she'll tell you your
name is Chuck Spadina there you go why
don't we just call you Casey
Reeves my heart got your wounded stuffed
slings and arrows huh I think that's an
error wicking the whole time and the
whole shebang in 4d in VR an incredible
drama you gotta put a movie together
stuff even though you counted absolutely
sometimes it just gets tough but yeah
we're hoping that we got high hopes for
[Music]
speed
hot-air balloon yeah well it wouldn't be
called speed it would be called no drop
I don't know yet I haven't worked it out
I was just spitballing one of those like
you know those vans that they take the
elderly around
oh yeah yeah I'm driving Danny's driving
because I don't remember where I am
where are we going
when I scream you should
I'm driving now we're just old we're
just all the people old modernized we're
like a fine wine this film doesn't have
a lot of physical action in it is that
harder to play for you or easier yeah
it's not harder we took my parent yeah
so we kind of went the other route and
instead of my parent yeah there's the
arms my parent there are a lot of birds
in the movie we didn't harm it you say
that it might be a classic is is it's
really nice we hope so I mean you never
know right but I mean we just hope
people like what we're doing anyway
anyway anyway it's really nice to hear
him thank you for sharing that but you
just call Stardust baby I know that's it
I was there how was your travel agent
there's like new selling drugs tonight
Medina is what I look like
hi sir were lost they're soaking wet
soaking wet yes
and one of the women in the film is
married to the director Eli Roth
yes it's wife yes and you have a very
explicit sexy letter yeah very was that
more uncomfortable then then they
usually are oh not for me to make like
every day like I can't wait okay okay
you're right yes yes sometimes you're
just shooting guys twice in the head
yeah you got to make sure then if I get
thrown off of something then Jackson
does his thing good if you want it to
but you just want no one kicking boy no
yeah I could get hit by a car but you
know hospital
he's like or you can hit by car once one
we gotta go yeah last film book that's
it yes did like to fight on a horse it's
fun does that not make this at all bad
it's a little big but the horse but the
horse is real you could get you could
get thrown and trampled yeah you can die
but the thing is let's go that far but
yeah that's true come off the saddle
you're supposed to fall under it held
onto the pommel excuse me it's fine and
then shoot someday but complete damsel
in distress and excuse us for a moment
I'm obviously didn't know I had a crush
on her
I can't believe you both had crushes on
each other and you you were so scared we
were working well I know but well what's
such a wonderful person
I kind of want to walk yeah no she's not
she's not here but the balding pudenda
Zenda what is that oh wait do I want to
know what this there was once a time
when John wick realizes that half of the
dog population would dusted out a ton of
this snap oh my gosh what's your
favorite me in the easy my favorite me
yeah of yourself I'm know I'm not really
familiar with my memes I know it's a
great statement what they just said yeah
okay you play the games what no they sat
on your head yet Oh cock-a-doodle-doo
really bad things for corner how many
tickles does it take to make an octopus
laugh tentacles fever fever you know
let's go that's my mother I'm stealing
it thank you is really going to be
breathtaking
[Applause]
all breathtaker you do what you won't
you County waves
[Applause]